[Offscreen voice]
Games can be a lot of fun can't they?
There's good sportsmanship. Do you know what that means?
Five years ago I began training in martial arts after
having been a dancer for decades.
What started out as a sideline interest spiraled rapidly
into an obsession.
Sparring in particular captured my imagination. I was
fascinated by the way this physical, aggressive,
competitive practice could yield such an
extraordinary sense of community.
My explanation is that sparring allows us
to manage competing positions with
respect. If I'm trying to punch you and
you're trying to kick me in the head we
disagree on a pretty basic level.
[Offscreen voice] Good sportsmanship
But we agree as to the terms of our interaction.
[Offscreen voice] Play fair
At the end we shake hands and most of the
time we actually mean it.
This is an interesting metaphor for social reality.
Political theorist Chantal Mouffe says that
pluralistic democracy hinges not on
unity but on dissent. She maintains that
we can practice respect through
disagreement.
[Offscreen voice]
Take the results well. No matter whether you win or lose.
Currently in the United States we have a
disagreement problem. We find it hard to
debate political positions without
denigrating people. We have come to see
opposition as inherently invalid.
If the political theorists are right, this
disrespect for disagreement does not
bode well for democracy.
It would be naive to suggest that we could simply
play fight our way to a more just world.
But it is equally naive to assume that
our actions outside the realm of
politics have no effect on the political sphere.
Physical play allows us to manage
competing positions with respect. Whether
we take that opportunity and whether we
learn from it is up to us.